The Evil Dead can never die.
From the new cast to what that 'R' rating
means, here's everything you need to know
about Evil Dead Rise.
Let's go.
Originally, Evil Dead Rise was headed for
HBO Max, but a funny thing happened on the
way to the streamer.
First, David Zaslav decided to emphasize theatrical
releases after taking over Warner Bros. Secondly,
Deadline reports that when the film's trailer
played at the trade show CineEurope, people
ate it up, proving the film was good enough
for theaters.
So when can we expect to get in line and buy
some tickets?
Well, we'll get to see Evil Dead Rise hit
theaters on April 21, 2023, as announced via
Bruce Campbell's Twitter account.
The actor also shared a first-look photo of
the film, which showed a smiling Deadite leering
through an apartment's blood-soaked peephole.
Interestingly enough, when Evil Dead Rise
releases in 2023, it won't be the only horror-comedy
that month.
The flick will be competing against Renfield,
which stars Nicholas Hoult as Renfield and
Nicolas Cage as his master, Dracula.
It'll be interesting to see which horror-comedy
walks away dominant.
"Now, let's eat!"
Throughout the Evil Dead franchise, there
has been one constant — someone reads an
evil book and unleashes the forces of hell.
In the first two Evil Dead movies, we watch
this horror show play out in a cabin in the
middle of nowhere, with a group of young people
getting picked off and possessed by sadistic demons.
Of course, the big difference between the
two films is that The Evil Dead is more or
less straight horror while Evil Dead II is
much heavier on the comedy.
"Who's laughing now?"
Things get weird in Army of Darkness when
franchise hero Ash Williams goes back to the
Middle Ages to fight a skeleton army.
And in 2013's Evil Dead, things get gorier
than ever when a group of friends hole up
in a cabin and release the Deadites.
But what will Evil Dead Rise be about?
Will it follow the standard Evil Dead formula
of a cabin in the woods, or will it get a
bit more creative a la Army of Darkness?
Well, this time, the Deadites are headed to
Los Angeles, and they plan to unleash havoc
on an apartment complex.
The official synopsis reads,
"[A] road-weary Beth pays an overdue visit
to her older sister Ellie [...] The sisters'
reunion is cut short by the discovery of a
mysterious book deep in the bowels of Ellie's
building, giving rise to flesh-possessing
demons and thrusting Beth into a primal battle
for survival."
In the first three Evil Dead films the franchise
was anchored by the shotgun-toting, chainsaw-wielding
Ash Williams, played by the one and only Bruce
Campbell.
"Shop smart.
Shop S-Mart…you got that??"
In the 2013 installment, the focus shifted
to Mia, played by Jane Levy, a woman struggling
with drug addiction who must also face an
onslaught from hell when she tries to go cold
turkey.
So who will be leading Evil Dead Rise?
Lily Sullivan will be playing the lead role
of Beth, who goes to visit her single mom
sister and finds herself facing an apartment
complex full of Deadites.
You may have seen Sullivan in miniseries like
Picnic at Hanging Rock or movies like Mental.
Opposite her, Alyssa Sutherland will play
Ellie, the mother of three living in the apartment
complex, whose life gets even more complicated
with the appearance of the flesh-bound Necronomicon.
The first three Evil Dead films were famously
directed by Sam Raimi, who went from microbudget
filmmaker to mainstream director on the success
of this trilogy.
The 2013 Evil Dead was helmed by Fede Álvarez,
who kept things intense with his two other
features — Don't Breathe and The Girl in
the Spider's Web.
So who's in charge of all the mayhem, murder,
and madness this time around?
Evil Dead Rise will be directed by Lee Cronin.
Sure, he isn't a household name yet, but we
have a feeling he will be soon.
At the moment, Cronin has just one released
film to his name — 2019's uber-creepy The
Hole in the Ground.
That film follows a single mother in Ireland
who suspects her son might not actually be
her boy anymore.
Raimi, who's also the executive producer on
Evil Dead Rise, was so impressed with Cronin's
work that he hand-picked him to direct the
new Evil Dead film.
Speaking with /Film, Raimi said,
"'I loved 'The Hole in the Ground.'
[...] I thought, 'This is a really great director.'
And we met, and we talked, and he said he
really liked 'The Evil Dead.'
And I said, 'Then why don't you make the new
one?
I think you're just the kind [of] guy I'd
like to do it."
That's high praise from the man who conjured
the Evil Dead franchise into existence.
The two people most closely associated with
the Evil Dead franchise are the two who brought
the series to life — director Sam Raimi
and star Bruce Campbell.
Without these titans of horror, we wouldn't
have Ash Williams duking it out with undead
monsters, sawing off his own possessed hand,
or reigning supreme as the king of S-Mart.
However, neither one will be reprising their
original positions for Evil Dead Rise.
So will these two be involved with Evil Dead
Rise?
Fortunately, the answer is yes.
Both Raimi and Campbell will be serving as
executive producers, along with Robert Tapert,
who's been involved with the franchise since
the first film.
And Campbell has had nothing but positive
things to say about the film, telling Collider,
"[Evil Dead Rise] does not suck in the least.
Lee Cronin did a great job.
... It's a very European 'Evil Dead.'"
We're assuming Campbell is referencing European
horror sensibilities, although we don't know
if he's talking about Italian giallo, French
Extremity, or some other style.
Whatever we're getting, it's sure to be scary.
Raimi told /Film,
"It's terrifying, and it's going to knock
people's socks off."
If you know anything about the Evil Dead series,
then you know it's not exactly a PG-rated franchise.
The first film scared up the dreaded NC-17,
with the subsequent entries all earning an
R-rating with their severed limbs and geysers
of gore.
So what will Evil Dead Rise be rated?
Will it compare to previous entries, or will
it go the route of so many modern movies and
play it safe with an audience-friendly PG-13?
Well, never fear, Deadite diehards.
Evil Dead Rise is gonna keep things nasty.
According to Fangoria, the 2023 film is officially
rated R. How come?
As you might expect, Lee Cronin's upcoming
movie earned the big bad R due to "strong
bloody horror violence and gore, and some
language."
Obviously, you can't have an Evil Dead film
without delivering on the kills.
Well, Army of Darkness isn't exactly the hardest
R, but from everything we've heard, it seems
likely this one will have more in common with
the first two films and Fede Álvarez's installment.
If you're at work, watch out.
The red band trailer for Evil Dead Rise isn't
messing around.
The trailer begins with possessed mother Ellie,
cooking the world's worst batch of scrambled
eggs and describing a lovely dream ... where
she violently murders her whole family.
Clearly, paging through the Necronomicon and
playing that old creepy record her kid found
was a mistake.
It's always a mistake.
From there, we watch as scalps get ripped
from heads, Deadites swallow shards of glass,
and our bloodied hero Beth guarding a group
of poor kids from their very undead mom.
"Mom?"
"Mommy's with the maggots now."
Yes, that Evil Dead staple — the chainsaw
— does make an appearance, promising plenty
of severed limbs and arterial sprays, and
we're also terrified to see what happens with
that cheese grater.
When it comes to iconic horror franchises,
few are as extensive as the Evil Dead.
This series has 5 movies of varying continuity,
a three-season television series, and multiple
video games.
"You're kind of like a young me.
Deadites ruined your life and you're hot as
hell."
Thanks to all this content, the Evil Dead
storyline can be a bit confusing for new fans
to wrap their head around.The very first Evil
Dead movie pits Ash Williams and his friends
against otherworldly demons while they're
stuck in a remote woodland cabin.
With Ash as the only survivor, his story continues
into the events of Evil Dead II and Army of
Darkness as he slowly and surely becomes a
Deadite-killing, chainsaw-handed hero.
"Now, let's talk about how I get back home."
Following his time in the Middle Ages during
Army of Darkness, Ash spends the next 30 years
as a total loser working at ValueStop before
accidentally reading from the Necronomicon
once again to initiate the plot of Ash vs
Evil Dead.
Now, it's important to understand that the
world of Evil Dead Rise is supposedly linked
to the original trilogy rather than the 2013
reboot titled Evil Dead.
Some key elements are carried over from what
came before, however, such as the Necronomicon
and the appearance of horrifying Deadites.
Evil Dead Rise has had a slightly complicated
development history, as have many installments
in this franchise since its beginnings in
1981.
This whole mess started back in 2013 after
director Fede Álvarez was given free rein
to make his own remake of the original film.
Evil Dead reimagines the events of the first
movie with an emphasis on realistic gore,
nuanced characters, and more modern horror.
Additionally, completely new characters are
added to the canon including new heroine Mia
Allen, although Ash Williams himself does
make a small cameo appearance in a post-credits scene.
Following the release of Evil Dead, Álvarez
was slated to make a sequel to his reboot
with the backing of Sam Raimi and Bruce Campbell,
but things stalled as Álvarez found success
with his own original Don't Breathe series.
The Uruguayan filmmaker even tweeted a poll
back in 2018 asking fans which of his big
movies they'd want to see a sequel of and
then expressed his disappointment in the results.
He told MovieWeb,
"When I tweeted that I was interested in seeing
what people prefer.
[...] Unfortunately, 'Evil Dead 2' won.
Which, I guess I would have preferred 'Don't
Breathe 2' to win because it's one of my own creations.
Obviously 'Evil Dead' has the bigger following.
So that's what happened."
It seems he ultimately decided to go his own
way, since that proposed sequel morphed into
an entirely new spin-off movie now known as
Evil Dead Rise without Álvarez at the helm.
There's something special about bloody, gory
cult horror movies that get certain types
of people frothing at the mouth.
Evil Dead has proven to be one of the most
popular franchises of its kind with seemingly
endless fans inspired by the way Sam Raimi
and Bruce Campbell merged the genres of horror
and comedy seamlessly together.
Indie filmmakers everywhere have cited Evil
Dead as a fundamental touchstone of their
own desire to make no-budget movies, with
some pretty big names in entertainment pointing
to Raimi's work as inspiration such as Peter
Jackson and Edgar Wright.
Even filmmakers as prestigious as the Coen
brothers got their start editing for Sam Raimi
on The Evil Dead — at least, Joel did, according
to the story.
The filmmaking style of The Evil Dead even
left an impact on the Coens' own work, most
notably in their films Blood Simple and Raising
Arizona.
That said, this is a franchise that has consistently
produced commercially successful and critically
acclaimed content that fans can't get enough
of.
Overall, the franchise has made over $150
million on a relatively small budget.
Furthermore, the films are constantly screened
at fan events and around Halloween, which
shows just how much people love to see Deadites
get cut in half with a chainsaw.
The newest installment will no doubt be just
as…
"Groovy."